each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay it's a pleasure to have today
Angeles on atom bomb on from University
College London angela is professor of
human Center technology and head of
information security research at UCL and
adam ism is one of her PhD students
angelo really doesn't need much of an
introduction among other you shouldn't
working on trust and security and
usability for for for longer than most
of us have known about that problem ah
so without much further ado but when one
interesting thing we were at a workshop
in in Cambridge a couple of weeks ago
and Alma quittin of Google said that you
know whenever she tries to think of
users she has a little Angela in her
head telling her what you should do so
today so that we can all listen to it
the floor is yours thanks Scott like
very for the introduction yet so
basically we've split the talk sort of
like it in two parts I'm going to sort
of start from the usability side and and
then Adams gonna take over for the
economics to put in some of the
economics perspective and then we'll
bring the whole thing together at at the
end yes sir so just want to basically
briefly look at what this talk today is
this really it's rather than talking
about one specific study I wanted to
sort of i give give my view it's sort of
like it's a summary of a paper i'm
working on at the moment about where
usable way I think usable security is
really going or should be going you know
basically what have we achieved in the
last ten years and it's that really
enough and is it really solving the
problem and they wanted me basically you
can guess what the acts rates yeah I
don't think we are and basically I want
to sort of like represent the
perspective that we've come come to you
know what really is the problem and can
we can we solve it and I think the
answer is that we need to basically use
the economics of security as a framework
for making decisions about what's useful
and what's not not usable so it's call
my candy said I've been working on this
problem for a long time and for those of
you some of you will have heard this
story before but
for those who don't know me i started in
1996 and it started with a phone call
from a company that i was doing some
some work with on a completely different
usability issue so used to work on
internet video conferencing basically
yeah I started that at a time when
somebody around here said this internet
thing it will never take off but and
and but basically so naturally will work
quite a lot with bt which is which was
the the the state phone company in the
UK melt and of course became privatized
and in this this phone call was about
and really this is this talk today it's
basically coming full circle you know I
think it was we're still coming back to
exactly the problem where we started and
that doesn't make me a very optimistic
that was solved so the phone call from
somebody who said we have the problem
the accountants are complaining about
the cost of the health discs that we're
running to reset employee passwords just
to give you an approximate idea at the
time BTW had four hundred thousand
employees worldwide and they employed
they had a call center where they
employed over a hundred people who did
nothing else all day long but reset
passwords for beauties own company
employees and their hat additional help
disks which were we're dealing with what
was in there what used to be this thing
called ISDN for those of you old enough
to remember it basically that were
dealing with resets for for those
customers and then there was the BT
internet that was starting out and
basically on bt internet about half of
all the cords they were fielding on that
held discs were login related so as it
is it was a massive problem and you know
basically did the cost had tripled every
year for three years in a row and the
accountant said where's this going you
know and they asked me to do a study to
basically look at in you know why do our
employees these stupid users as they
literally as the guy literally said to
recut why can't they remember their
passwords and we will publish this paper
which some of you you would have looked
at and the key thing is you know
basically the answer is you're asking
them to do something that's
not humanly possible you know at these
people had between 60 and 65 different
passwords they were told not to reuse
the same password over different systems
there had to be cryptographically strong
they had six-digit some of these
credentials were six digit pins that had
to be changed every 30 days and so on
and basically that's not possible you
cannot remember this without writing it
down it's just not not doable but the
consequence of what was going on there
is still something that I'm afraid we're
seeing today is that if you look at the
attitude that the users develop as a
result of being faced with security
policies and being asked to do things
which are basically not doable or at
least not doable unless you dedicate
your and I you know most of your
productive working working day to it is
that they start they lose any respect
for security they see it as something
that's simply a pain in the neck and
something that's not worth bothering
with you know and it's certainly not not
something they would they would treasure
in their field I want to be a part of
and that is a problem that's really you
know that's a serious problem if people
look at it that way you know if you
don't win the hearts and minds off of
those people then basically my argument
is you end up companies end up paying
for it through the nose and some of them
are started to realize that a lot of
them still call haven't and I think by
the time the majority of organizations
realize how much they're paying for it
they're going to be very angry and you
know it i think they're going to be
asking some tough questions of security
professionals and so basically we this
paper was published in 1999 are my wit
enough course published where Johnny
can't encrypt at the same time so this
has been like you know good over ten
years now wife we got what what did
happen well you could argue a lot of
hand you know we've got soups with with
God rust because rasam and Bruce always
needs to do their own thing you know
their starters the security and human
behavior conference we've had with
certainly we now have regularly we have
papers on on this in ACM conferences
like I and ccs usenix you know new
security paradigms workshop we've had
fed some some some books on the topic at
the universities you now can take
modules on
usable security or people in security
myself teach teach a course at UCL where
I work in an Oxford government has kind
of working up to this at least in the UK
i'd share to share a panel of people who
wrote a white paper on a courtroom and
vulnerabilities in security systems and
last year some of some of the people
here attended it the US National Academy
of Sciences held to held a workshop a
two-day workshop on the unusable
security and privacy the report of which
I still haven't seen I don't know if
anybody anybody else look how across I
still haven't seen it so some of us work
were there representing there and in the
workshop and discussion so clearly I
mean there is an acknowledgement that
this is a problem we should do something
about it and has it made security usable
I think not you know basically if you
look at some of the the predictions that
were made so so you know the the big
arguably the most famous usability guru
off the mall jakob nielsen sent into
thousands biometrics are highly usable
you know and they would replace
passwords because they're so useful and
and the whole problem would go away you
know um hasn't happened has it well if
I'm if I'm looking at it has happened
and what's been happening in usable
security research I mean if we just for
a minute now just focus on this
authentication problem is we've had a
whole bag you know a whole slew of
allegedly more usable authentication
mechanisms and I just like to walk you
through some of those you know basically
you have to give it to these people
they've been hanging on for for like
what 13 14 years now our past faces you
know graphical authentication mechanisms
there they're still there still there
they're still basically claimed it would
be a good idea to replace all your
passwords with pass faces logins and you
know this but it's it's really the
problem is and we had in 2009 we finally
had a paper that that did slightly
basically proved to the research
community something that was known in in
the commercial part because of a bar
click Add study that was never published
but everybody knew about which basically
said as soon
you have a second account with a pass vs
login forget it people get you know get
get completely confused and so you get
good long-term memorability as long as
you only have one of these you know and
after that is basically it just goes
downhill and you know you can get old
sorts of graphics I don't know why
anybody thinks that mouse thing you know
your your pin or your password in as
opposed to typing it will make it more
memorable but clearly some people think
I think it would be and you can have
like well you know there's the argument
is always pretty pictures let's give you
know surely people to memory for
pictures is much better than you know
for these like like meaning the strings
and characters and so you get these
ideas of like you know clicking on
various those things and when you look
at it you know inevitably basically you
know the security people will scream
from one side of the of the room like oh
but it's not secure then if you look at
the usability you should scream back
well you know and it's taking people
like in a 15 minutes to basically enroll
in this this thing and executing the
login takes you know anything from 30
seconds upwards and that really doesn't
doesn't help you know so this whole idea
of that you could use that that you know
there's this whole I think this is this
quest is misguided to come up with one
mechanism that could to replace them all
you know like you know 11 of vegetation
mechanism to replace them all you know
to rule them all I think that's
basically where the problem is is that
that that's just the wrong way of
looking looking at the problem you know
so if you've got you know but way back
in users are not the enemy we pointed
out you know that performance problems
within frequently use you know the vast
majority of performance problems come
from infrequently used passwords not
from frequently used one the reality is
is that for a frequently used password
we have automaticity and memorability is
not a problem performance is very hard
to beat you know the five seconds that
it takes to execute that is you need to
try it you know you you're going to be
hard pushed to come up with another
authentication mechanism that's going to
be as quick to execute right even a
biometric know sort of like standard
basically on a biometric 12
seconds is a performance level that is
very hard to beat you know use very hard
to push it down you need to seriously
invest you know basically Disney add
some at one point put employed 70 people
for 18 months on a project to try and
get the fingerprint authentication on
the gates in all under down under 12
seconds you know and they're managed to
get around the 10 seconds but you know
serious a serious project to tune and
try and actually get it get it to work
so on the other hand with infrequently
used you know you'd happily most users
would very happily trade something that
takes unit do something it takes 30
seconds if you know if it's something
that they can remember and so you know
and this is actually one of the things
that completely flummoxed as me is
whenever I look at anybody discussing
usability of authentication you know
that that really we should radically
just split it into infrequently and
frequent the user authentication and not
try and use the same thing for both you
know it's it's you need basically to
trade memorability for execution time
when it comes to infrequent Lawrence and
clearly went something that people you
know need to need to you know when you
if you're talking screen locks you know
if you have a master password that you
used to get into your main system and
you need to keep the screen log on and
and you know basically most people type
the stuff 30 times a day at the moment
you know you need it to be quick really
quick and easy and error-free
performance now had all these kind of
things are graphical passwords you know
like like deja vu interestingly enough a
few years ago the people people up in
Toronto isn't it basically paul von
orchards is it is it ottawa thank you
sorry thank you yes porfa no shirts
group a lot of antonio kiss on allah 4g
and they go seek he came up with this
persuasive crude cute click points
mechanism which starts to finally take
the authentication with a graphical
mechanism down to to a level that i
would say starting to get competitive
you know so basically between sort of
seven to nine seconds depending on
exactly how many pictures you're using
and it also this mechanism quite neatly
avoids a lot of the security port
that other graphical mechanisms have
which is because wherever you click on
just have a starter image and wherever
you click it will bring up another image
and it's just if you click on the right
and on your basically your point on the
image it will bring up the the next
image that you need and you click then
on the next point and the next one so it
doesn't give the attacker any any
inclination what the correct answer is
you know so i think that's that's
basically sort of like the best
performance we had but still whether it
will read it would really replace you
know for people who are used to
basically typing a lot and how long the
keyboard whether it's really the right
mechanism I don't yeah so here you can
basic you see it will bring up wherever
you click drawing you know basically
that it started with draw a secret and
then Jeff young from Newcastle
University in the UK when when the the
security people scream from one side of
the room but it's not secure the number
of the shapes that people come up with
is very limited and so Jeff said well I
can make them drawn a bigger variety of
things by putting some pictures
underneath and of course it's got this
instant appeal it's like it whenever you
show pretty pictures you know people go
to an hour thank you this really you
know whether you'd really want to with a
handheld device down there and start
drawing on your things you need two
together and it's it's again you know if
whether it's on your iPhone or on one of
these devices you know if you look at
how long it takes you know to to
basically enter a strong password on you
know on an iPhone keypad when you need
to suddenly start toggling between three
different different keyboard displays
you know suddenly you're up to weigh
over 30 seconds for for standard in
entry at these kind of things grit sure
so it's an idea offer this is a one-time
pin the you know the whole idea is like
that that attackers can capture your
credential ones but so here the idea is
you get a different pin every time
because you see it whenever you want to
login or you want to basically pay it
will display this grid and you have a
secret shape on it and you read off
the you know you read off your pin from
the location and enter it and the
security people scream from one side of
the room that's one secure because the
number of the types of shapes that
people will pick is very predictable so
basically people will pick simple shapes
like squares you know or or lines and
they'll inevitably pig shapes that touch
on an edge somewhere and that basically
takes it down to to a much smaller sort
of much smaller thing memorability
performance was actually we did a trial
on this which we were publishing in the
British to HCI conference this year
which is it's actually reasonably good
even after long periods of time so it's
it's you know it's potential but
basically things are getting more
ridiculous by by the month as far as I'm
concerned you know basically we fed
authentication by Rorschach inkblot test
two years ago mu Z pass singing at the
computer basically we've had a couple of
years before that thinking your password
and then the EEG reads off the thing a
thing at the back in ish brucey got very
excited over like you know you think
your password and on on an fMRI scanner
you can then see you know where it's
going you know the biometric seen I
think we can illustrate by you know the
biometrics that we have are so good that
every month somebody comes up with a
different kind of parametric you could
use so you know we've had everything you
know with from ear you know your ear is
unique and and you just take a picture
of that now it's the nose it's one of
the latest thing we've seen you know
which keeps suggesting to me it's like
if they're desperate is scrabbling
around for for something else to use you
know none of the existing ones are
working well enough to get you the
performance at you know at a reasonable
level of effort and cost so we also have
had this like sorry I had to put this a
suggestion of you know you're right
after you might bring up your friends in
the middle of the night to us and to
give you some codes you know that you've
previously stored with them
said they way you know a week to
actually complete your education well
which is you know which is which is what
exactly makes my argument you know it's
like if you really need to get back you
know if it's for something that doesn't
matter fine but if you really need to
get back into and you know if you really
need to get something done and that's
not acceptable and you you can't even
even wait to the morning so I just
really want a question of whether this
is you know whether this is really you
know it's this really a stuff that's
going to work for four people out there
I think we can say that in the real
world you know its mate frightening a
little different you know you basically
they've been several companies as I said
all cute us to pass faces you know this
guy's just keep going I don't know how
they do it but somehow they do and but
other companies have gone bust you know
I don't know sort of like if you if you
basically look at you know we do press
this was a bit where you they use image
categories so you basically could say
like you know I've got like at the kitty
category and the dog category and then
it doesn't show you the same picture
every time but you get different you
just need to recognize so this is a
picture of a dog and this is a picture
of a baby you read off the letter or the
number and all you had to do was type in
two lettuce and it's combined with a
soft token on on your machine you know
that that's what that's all these these
things he seems a lot of people with
good technical problems also go bust yes
Wow yeah good night he was a danger
group of us except but that's and that
that's actually exactly my argument you
know they may technically be quite good
but I mean Deena this this basically
this company went bust i think the earth
a maid to the made the news because the
employees could they couldn't pay the
last month's salary so they told the
employees to take the computers film
instead in india of payment yeah in the
biometrics area pay by touch vary wildly
tart it was floating on the stock market
i mean there is some you know there may
have been some some business
irregularities but there's also
definitely that the supermarket chains
who try to collaborate here basically
just found you know that a couple of
months of use and and you can throw the
scanners away you know they're just not
robust enough to take you know people
coming in with all sorts of like you
know sand and dirt and things on
hand and it's just not you know it's
just not a workable solution in the long
run pathmark attention to me
and what's what's us became sick okay
all right yes irsa yeah and that is it
widely deployed and used always lazy
depleted use doesn't work it doesn't
deployed in here it doesn't yeah yes it
doesn't so yes psyche yeah we could
university I've just picked a few
examples here we could could could pick
a few more I mean in the UK we've had
we've had basically these kind of sleeve
readers where you basically insert your
your credit card into a reader and it
gives you a time code and the banks are
saying yes it's great you know we've
rolled it out to X number of people but
the truth is of course it's you know
either you use it or you give up the
idea of using online banking you know
and so they're they're forcing people
and they see they sort of like they will
then quietly say oh those few cranks you
know who don't want to use it you know
they you know good riddance you know let
them go somewhere else you know they're
just depending than anywhere but
actually when when we do so as know
people complain to us quite a lot that
they find it you know that they've
constantly find that they're on the road
you know a lot of the people who use
online banking have a nomadic lifestyle
and their kids basically keep forgetting
to bring the device along and then you
know they say in the end I need to ring
up my wife at home tell her where the
devices and give her all my credentials
so she can in you know impersonate me
and pay the bill on time so we're not
you know we're not ending up with with a
fine or a bad credit record you know
that's what what's really going on you
know when the banks are saying it's
working it's working fine and cormac and
and and his colleague head is it is it
dinnae Vanessa the dundies study and and
this is like how people how users really
cope you know their base in and we've
we've basically confirmed this they will
start to make a strategy of grouping
different accounts into according to
their perceived risk or sensitivity and
then reuse passwords across different
accounts and typically also what they do
is they they have like you know there's
their most secure password and when they
have to when that gets gets expired by
the system that they use it on there
then try and roll it down and roll it
across the different other types of
groups that they have so the sharing is
is still basically pretty rampant and
and the rate of forgetting is due
still pretty rampant you know and it's
it's kind of like a solicitation from
colleagues at the US Department of
Transport you know who basically said
like this is really how users feel about
it you know they feel like it's a
pressure cooker still you know all the
demands that are being made on them from
from authentication the paper we had at
KY this year is it was basically sort of
like doing more detailed study following
people around over a day asking them to
write down every time they had to log in
and even though both of these companies
have single fine on the actual number of
passwords that the users had in this
company was at least as high as it was
ten years ago over ten years ago when we
did the first study and the SSO makes
makes in the factor in the end little
difference because so much of the
services are being out sourced you know
there's third-party services and then of
course they bring their own
authentication if you have like
Bloomberg or Reuters services in the
bank you know they have their own
authentication making this and thats
that they have to use because four
varieties of Bloomberg it's a licensing
issue a revenue protection issue and
then are going to bring it under the
earthen and under the single sign-on
that the bank is using for for for their
own systems so really you know we found
that people were still complaining they
were still spending quite a lot of time
physically typing just typing things in
and they reuse and sharing was still
very common so that they were recycling
the passwords across exactly as we found
in the in the end consumers requirements
sharing between groups between members
of a group emailing passwords runs quite
common and the other thing that was very
nice we found that basically most people
now and either proactively or reactively
use the password reminders to get
themselves a nice basically little file
store of all their passwords they'll all
be sitting in an email folder in one of
their their their email you know which
of course is another vulnerability also
still the the quest you know to try and
keep the cost of managing passwords down
in the organizations that we looked at
is still increasing it's still going on
now so they're basically saying
helped us are too expensive you know if
you get reset rates of I mean most
companies will balk at reset rates even
around three percent and say it's too
expensive per month you know per month
most of them are saying anything under
basically if it's over one percent a
month utterly unacceptable some of them
are even saying you know basically if
it's if it's if it's a tenth of a
percent a month you know the cost is
unacceptable no no they're saying it's
like if you know these are basically
typically they're sitting on either
three-month expiry or 150 day expiry
cycles but they're saying is if we have
to reset per month one percent you know
the courses and that they've run
basically one of the things they've
tried is to have generic help desks
which also do the password resets and of
course they find you know the problem is
they are and you know the people who
work on this help desk now I have to
develop a split personality where
they're generally trying to be helpful
and get things done very quickly but on
the other hand you know you you're
talking about one of these organization
to bank you know where you have people
ringing in from various sites you don't
really know those people you know and
that when you're trying to be helpful
you know when when somebody says I've
locked myself out you know you're very
quickly giving the credentials to social
engineering attacker and that's so
that's basically a problem so is it
actually is the question is it possible
to get something that is secure and
works well we think it is it is possible
but we just have to to accept you know
we have to basically I think change the
perspective and and really look more
from what's actually really what really
does acceptable and unusable mean from
the point of users and from the point of
the main activity that they that they do
and start to develop basically a way of
measuring economically what that
workload is costing us so at that point
I want to head over to to Adam to
introduce you of where we've taken the
usability work into into an economics of
security framework
thanks Angelo hmm so yeah I'm going to
just going to go through some of the
economic background we were trying to
put together to support a different way
of making decisions about security and
what we should i do to comment the kind
of problems i need angela is talking
about so my background is not economics
at all is it something that I've read up
on as part of getting interested in a
way of tackling this so but I will cover
the sort of sort of basics that are
underpinning some of this the key
concept is this idea of preference and
indifference which is basically about
and consumers making purchasing choices
now the reason that economics kind of
came into our and discussions in the
first place is that it's a really old
and very ones to em field that's got a
lot of theories that are embedded and
have been studied for a long time so
we're trying to feed back on there on
the success and the end they're sort of
credentials of a can always if you like
okay so when they talk about and
preference and indifference that what
they're really saying is given to bundle
of bundles of goods a and B and i've
used dvds and video games to serilla
straight this and you can ask someone to
make a choice would you prefer bundle a
a bun will be and by asking them out a
series of these questions you can build
up a picture of what they're sort of
purchasing choices are going to be like
and an interesting point when you're
doing this is to find the point at which
they're indifferent which options they
get I at which point they find and the
two options to be equivalent then you
can start changing the options and
trying to figure out the rates at which
and they they like to change that I how
much they prefer one thing to another so
another second example there and if they
prefer DVDs twice as much as games if we
offer them seventies DVDs and five games
if we take one DVD off we have to
replace it with two games to keep the
bundle equivalent and this point they
will be happy to select either of those
because it fits into their into their
purchasing preference to to keep their
and utility as it's cool that sort of
overall satisfaction with with the offer
the same so from this from sort of
analyzing and sort of building a picture
of these and purchasing choices we can
construct an indifference Cove which
essentially shows the rate at which
you're willing to trade off
in these two goods so the curve is a
sort of ice our utility if you like so
all the points on that curve the
consumer is equally satisfied with the
options there that they're being given
as we reduce one if we take away the
dvd's we have to replace it with games
to keep their satisfaction a identical
and and this is a this notion of trade
office what is very important we don't
understand how an entity trades off
between between two options and then we
can sort of start understand their
behavior on the under certain situations
so in the consumer sense when you're
because we will make trade-offs when
they're purchasing goods and as as in
the utilities a deep sorry the
indifference curve example and as we a
trade-off occurs when increasing one
forces you to decrease another and this
is very well under student in economics
and not necessarily so well understood
it in insecurity for example this is a
classic security objectives of CIA it's
often fitted the confidentiality and
integrity are and I sorry forms in
charging availability or a post and it's
increasing one means you have to
decrease the other but it's a fairly
nebulous boundary the definitions vary
depending who you talk to and it's not a
very easy thing to understand so what
we're trying to do is trying to get into
this and try and find out how people are
making these choices and how they're
sort of trading off between between
these sort of security questions when
they're presented with them so we
interviewed employees from all ranges
sort of security managers down to the
reception staff across two companies one
a kind of more technical company and one
a financial institution and from their
answers we were sort of them sort of
picture came up and a key point in their
answers is that the perspective that you
take is exceedingly important and
everyone has their own view on on what
the cost is and this can lead to such
can lead to quite a big discrepancy
between what an organization might think
the cost is and what the actual
individual that you're that's actually
an undertaking any activity might
perceive it to be as well so when we're
factoring these things are one weird
sort of trying to build up a picture and
a bit of a model for this we have to
consider
a whose perspective we're taking and
actually consider what their perceived
cost is rather than what would the
actual measurable cost or any kind of
you sort of arbitrary truth value might
be and right down to the point that it
costs to one entity might be considered
to be a benefit to the other and this
particularly when you have a clash
between organizations and individuals
you know where your organization might I
think great you know we're going to lock
all access to social networking
scientists this means that our we're
much more secure and we're not be
leaking information and they see that as
a benefit and the guys on the ground to
use that to communicate or to make touch
with clients or to do research fine is a
massive imposition we perceive that I
are you saying that for some people the
place to find some security mechanism
he is not as bad as Nicholas but the
responder you know that there really
only takes you know five seconds of it
for me but I really respond as though
yeah exactly now I'll point that until
more later but but also that the
circumstances for exactly the same task
mean if you come in at the start of the
day and you're fresh and ready to go and
sometimes open you just you know can you
run this somewhere informer you blind no
problem and if you're just about to walk
out the door and songs can do exactly
the same thing it'll seem like a much
more own risk short so understanding
that while the task remains the same the
how the person doing it perceives it
that's a really important thing to get
hold of so from from these interviews
and from so I sandpeople these security
questions and how they'd respond to you
we were asked him about em I like how
that reactive encryption was mandated on
us bees and other things that change
their working day how they perceive this
of benefits of that and we could have
current this idea which we referred to
as the compliance budget which is M over
how individual as it says assess the air
the effort involved in the tasks they're
being presented with and again this idea
of perceived effort when they're
perceived effort exceeds what they see
is the benefit of that they start to
fill it that's a cost and and this is a
curative thing that eight that a is over
time and depends on how much they've
already been burdened as well and as the
users approach this this threshold so
the budget means literally that it's a
finite amount that people are willing to
put into compliance with the security
for most people security isn't their
primary tasks or something else they'd
rather we getting on with or it's
necessarily going with for them to get
them to get paid extra so as you
approach the limit of their of their
budget it becomes a security feels more
owner of the person doing it because
they're already quite burdened and that
means that the organization has to put
from their end more time effort and
resources into trying to ensure
compliance from there from their
workforce so this is a this is a kind of
sketch graph this is based on interview
so it not some sort of a numerical data
to back it up but this is the kind of
behavior that we predict from the
answers we were getting from from the
workforce so the vertical axis is the
effort the organization is having to put
in to get compliance out of their their
workers and their you
and the horizontal axis is the effort
that the users are putting into
compliance the vertical dr. Linus is
this sort of this threshold this
compliance budget limit that we feel
people sort of run into so when the when
the individual effort is is low you know
the organization doesn't have to put
much effort into ensuring compliance
most people with these days have an
understanding the Securities is relevant
and important and they'll happily go
along with a few times but as you sort
of increasingly burden them and get
towards the threshold you know people
start to feel more disgruntled they're
feeling more sort of put upon this skirt
is getting in the way of what they're
trying to do and it becomes more
difficult to ensure their compliance
once you push people over the threshold
you know that is the kind of toys out of
the compound where people think when
they don't just dis stuff this I've had
enough and I want to get up my job and
they just start looking for work arounds
and they kind of abdicate from taking
part in securities as much as possible
at that point the user effort is really
is really you know they're not putting
any any energy into doing it in the
organizations who have to put all their
resources we have much more resources
into trying to get and this compliance
with this with this heavily overburdened
workforce hence why the fact that went
to you over the threshold again it kind
of ramps up to increasingly ridiculous
levels to try and enforce all this stuff
onto your onto your workforce so it is
possible to influence this this decision
no this this isn't a sort of you know
horribly an intractable problem yeah the
the guy in the middle is said every time
he's favored with the security task he's
going to make a compliance station am I
going to go along with it or I'm going
to try and seek an easier work around
that just get that's going to go in with
Mike with my day in a more efficient way
and there's you know there's sort of
them sort of good and bad if you like or
so nice and nasty ways of trying to
influence that this compliance decision
so we say this is basically a
cost-benefit analysis I like this or
economic thinking you and as I just said
this is recon perception is that users
are sort of stupid and lazy but
increasing research from from corners
and so people actually making pretty
rash decisions about about security
they're not just being you know sort of
arbitrarily dumb and avoiding it think
actually it's not it isn't actually
worth my time this kind of cost-benefit
analysis taking place and we want to
influence this in such a way that you
know we're going to increase the
benefits and reduce the cost and this
reduced
the thing is is probably the low-hanging
through here and so things like
designing this this is a school system
and you as I mentioned for what time of
day you do the task automated patching
is it's a nice example if you if when
you turn if we done in the morning it
says you know you're we're now going to
take a computer out of your hands or 15
minutes while we install practice and 42
restart that's really gets you off to a
bad start in the day you put that
decision in the hands of the users and
you say you know you have to patch at
some point today but you know when
you're ready please sort of click here
then you know when when they're going
off for lunch or taking a break or go
into a meeting they can do it security
remains exactly the same but the user
the cost user the effort they've
received going to put into it it
substantially reduced and without
changing the level of a level of
security that's an example of how design
and culture again trying to and this is
funny funny sort of and common idea
trying to increase the sort of awareness
of security in an organization but again
this goes back into this cost benefit
thing if you're more aware than needed
security then you see more benefit and
you reduce these situations in which the
you the effort appears to be a cost
because you're weighing it against the
sort of benefit on the on the sort of
slightly harsh assigns you can start
bringing and sanctions and monitoring to
sort of you know I through software
hardware to enforce sort of a policy or
you're trying to do as well and which em
again users would like to avoid running
afoul of Santa sang some things things
like that so what you're basically doing
then is rather there's no you're upping
you're upping the cost of failure to
comply basically in this sense which
makes it seem more attractive to go
along with them as long as the
compliance decision is made I mean all
that all the negative comes from the
organization itself
the idea of bad guy influencing the idea
that my decision is based on possibility
but bad outcome is not other than a
sanction of monitoring is absent right
hey what do you mean as in like they
fear the the fella back and consider to
make the degree what I'm worried about
what I'm worried about is somebody
notices that my passwords weave it into
the ER that I'm not complying in some
location and this is what this is about
in compliance in that sense I guess what
you're talking about then is is sort of
fit sort of slight into the culture
thing is that there if they if they are
if they fear the effects of every week
security then they see the benefit of
doing security and so it so it comes in
as a certain that side so I you know I
have had this this diagram is slightly
misleading to the green and red and I'm
thinking about changing because if
people sort of see it's kind of getting
bad but yeah ii and III see that being
rolled into the kind of constant being
aware of security in the seeing is a
good thing rather have that fear because
about the ratio between the soup
here it is but for all so these are the
two feedback channels are there because
the benefit we can't show the benefit
directly we have to amplify that channel
to other yeah yeah and obviously and the
reason it's a sort of point is it's of
cyclic form here as well as is that the
results of what you did last time
influence what you do what you do next
time as well if you don't comply and you
can and you sort of them get away with
it you might be more inclined to comply
next time because you're sort of fearing
the increased rate of sanctions you
might get by continual phase we comply
and likewise if you if you've been
complying all day and being a jolly good
you know employee then you've accepted a
lot of burden and that making might
might make you less likely to comply
next time because you're kind of
reaching towards your threshold as well
so it is you know this design isolate
decisions they're taking place in a sort
of overtime context and as well so this
is this is all this sort of compliance
thing and should I understand how users
are making this cross benefit and
decisions and trading off between
between their sort of choice but it is
interesting because it brings up this
idea of technical versus effective
security and this is I think an idea
that is important to push is that these
systems security relies heavily on on
users compliant to be effective and even
if a system is really well designed
technically if no one's using it
properly you're going to get really
really bad security out of it and this
creates a disconnect between what's the
supra dicted security what your what
your plan is have planned and what's
actually happening on the ground and you
know it's a historically and
stereotypically I suppose security is
planned by very technical minded people
who may not be so this is all right let
me just finish them that I'll give us
the equation and so you know who are
necessary very aware of these kind of
issues and you know process is really
neat idea it goes into the
authentication just talking about you
mandate this as sort of 12 character for
sophisticated chopra case looks like a
really solid nice posture is getting
resistant to to all kinds of gap attacks
difficult to show their serve difficult
to crack but it's going to rip down on a
post-it note so your discrepancy between
what you've planned and what the
real-life security or system is is it is
quite a mite
and and there's more so about the next
slide so let us jump in now the state
security realize and user compliance
social engineering also relies on user
compliance that is true and so it seems
that creating an environment where users
comply with with anything that's as good
as as from the security apartment unless
you've got really really clear statement
dope how do you know it comes from your
crew security people it may be that that
security is in fact not compatible with
compliance or that picnic if you're if
you're going for high compliance the
same exact exact strategy of your
attackers
I guess the and that's a centering point
I guess maybe I saw separate compliance
with existing policies with blind Lee
following orders I mean there is I bring
this up because read many of the emails
that we get at Microsoft in that every
previous employer and organization i've
been affiliated with there was no clear
policy about this is when you this is
how you know this is an email you're
supposed to comply with it comes from
blank and HR you're told you're supposed
to watch this compliance video and on
some of them you're lucky enough that
your organizational Shane actually does
point out this is important you should
do it but basically what they keep
beating into you is you're going to be
getting emails from random people within
your organization whose names you
haven't heard before comply with them do
it and if there's a good good super for
next year and you just send that email
to microsoft research you know redmond
all and see if tell people to watch a
video tip on someone yeah i think it is
it into point yeah and you know you
write like chem pushing it too far the
other way making people just going to be
going with it that does does open up
other screw you know this is but in the
old security planning involved wires
iteration that you put one fixed in
place you have to see the NOC
identification so yeah I think there's
yeah policy look we've let our issue
I gather the guy who his clothes and
taxpayer beautiful half the people in
Britain he didn't follow the rules but
the rules were so secret he was the
reason haha and well yes actually I
think it is pointing at another it's
basically it's linking to something you
know it's one one of the things that we
would actually say it's like a lot of
the security at the moment is it you
know the boxes that are drawn around the
apartment are far too small and and
there is you know basically big very few
organizations really have big picture
security where you know all this has
taken taken together so basically if you
are disseminating that kind of
information you better make sure that
your communication channels are you know
our working on that you know you
basically your employees can correctly
identify whether a communication is
coming from you know coming from who it
claimed to be with you know versus not
but a basically if you if you just keep
like pushing all this stuff down you
know people have no no reliable way of
telling whether it's really from one or
the other then of course it won't work
but but that again is like it was just
another you know a few things that I
never taught in most organizations are
never tired tied together wait so just
finish up mm-hmm so and brings on this
stuff together and think about
trade-offs in the contents of context of
security for and for a user in terms of
sort of generating and using passwords
we can say there's the sort of core
trade office between the ease of use of
the password in terms of sort of
memorability in there sort of cognitive
load that they're placed under by using
it and reasons to attack move towards a
more resistant password then this in
nine cases out of ten requires
increasing the burden of the user and
reducing its ease of use and and this is
engineering and relating back to this
idea of sort of em plan versus security
actually being delivered is that at some
point as you burn your users and you
push them towards the sort of compliance
limit they're going to start to adopt
insecure behaviors to cope with the
effort they're putting under you know
the password gets put on the post-it
note it gets shared with the colleagues
whatever the workaround is or whatever
the sort of technical mechanism
mechanism is the behavior the coping
mechanism will
introduced in securities into the
organization in order to cope with this
so this the implication this is that
your best security get so your best
security results from when you're asking
people to do and you're asked them to
take effort putting the F insecurity
that is it equipment or just below their
compliance Thresh on and which means
that's the security you should be
planning for as well now in the in the
instance of a technique very well plan
but very harsh and the user school
system and that's then is it encouraged
a whole bunch of workarounds you might
actually get more effective security by
by reducing or weakening your policy
down to below this sort of the threshold
where your users have been to adopt
insecure behaviors which you know I
think it come across as a slightly
counter counter intuitive notion but
understanding how users are going to
respond and what their behavior is going
to be as a result of your security
policy I think you know and the amos lee
is the delivered secures at the end not
you know try to push them into this mole
of this rigid security structure and you
know this the trailer sort of continued
them up into the organizations as well
if you're making your part is more
resistance to attack then they'll be
yeah then usability for the users is
going to go down this ear puts more
costs onto password resets and the
recent polls like engine was talking
about at bt as well so it is it eating a
lot of organizations run on a financial
basis looking to the bottom line you
know you can also save money by by you
know making your users not be having to
sort of go through this process and and
burden them too so understand this can
have benefits Security an accountant or
financial and financial rewards as well
join once you complete okay yeah okay
and so this be the importance of really
understanding the the cost is is
something dis recyclin it's a story that
that we've encountered again and again
looking we've just talked about about
authentication and passwords here but
we've seen similar bit patterns
basically imagine when it comes to two
basic you people encrypting you know
employees in organizations encrypting
the data digital certificates I should
basic say so we're currently trying to
give this is a better empirical these
ideas are better empirical basis so
they're currently we've
are now working with the third company
where we're conducting a hundred
interviews with employees basically from
both you know basically shop floor level
up to managerial level about compliance
and non-compliance with various with the
various policies the organization asked
and this would be followed by we
actually had when we when we first we
put an advert in the company newsletter
and we had 450 people volunteering to be
interviewed and this is taken more than
we can can really do so what we're now
planning to is after we've done 100
interviews we're going to pick sets of
policies that in effect various parts of
the organization and then do a survey
with the remaining volunteers where
we're going to ask them to to rate the
the effort level that's involved with
compliance and so we're hoping to build
a proper empirical basis for you know
where exactly these decision points lie
but I've also seen it in basically
working for the UK government you know
which has these ideas of let's put all
our government services online you know
else we can save like you know we can
Baisakhi plaque the big gap in the
household by just you know basically
closing down all the offices and all the
call centers and just make people
transact online with government but
basically the kind of you know the the
enrollment mechanism you know how a
citizen would prove to the government
though they they they it was designed by
GCHQ which is the security agency and
basically in a pilot trial that was done
it's like 19 out of the 20 people
couldn't didn't manage to successfully
enroll in it and all 20 of them said
there was no way they'd actually used
this similarly we're currently doing a
study with 30 people who are using open
ID they're very heavy internet users
quite technically service savvy and we
asked we introduce them to open ID and
ask them to use it for a week and to
just video themselves at home when
they're using it and basically we you
know basically we're but it's not and
the number of people who said at the end
of the week that they would use open ID
you know a wouldn't use of maddie is
pretty much you know it's very close to
the 30 people who are participating in
this you know because simply the the
what they're getting the effort is quite
huge and the perceived benefit of it is
just hard too low for them to get there
just go like no I've got other things
to do in my life I'm moving you know I'm
not I'm not doing this so ready to try
this like we want to say that we need to
go beyond the end this whole I think
just the idea that users are the enemy
and users are stupid it's just a very
unhealthy perspective just look at it as
you know as a neutral economic problem
of you know of basically effort and
benefits and that you need to strike the
right balance between efforts and
benefits so I basically go like you know
basically this idea of like you know
it's still even people who say like in a
human factors is a problem they're still
paint you know but the people are the
problem you know it's because they're
stupid it's because they don't care and
it's you know it's not i think basic
about bringing together usability and
the economics research we can
demonstrate its just people at you know
basically it's it's a question of effort
and and and that's basically we just
need it's it's a kind of discourse where
we need to tell security people you know
to just not basically keep putting these
negative connotations on it because also
the next thing then they always say it's
the solution is to educate users and i'm
going like no you know you're going to
educate them to spend more and more of
their their their daily time you know on
doing security related tasks you know
and now we're going to add the education
effort you know we have to add that time
on top of it as well it's just not not
realistic it's not going to happen so
really we have to stop overburdening
users it reduces the like you of
compliance and it ruins personal
productivity and organizational
productivity you know and we've we've
got various examples of that some of
them in the published work some is still
forthcoming part of the problem is is
that security at the moment is simply is
not designed to fit with you know it's
this idea that is one authentication
mechanism to rule them all you know we
just have to get away from that is there
are certain individual tasks and there
is in organizations in particularly you
need to design solutions that fit within
what what the organization is doing the
way it does its business you know the
idea is that there is a standard
security solution that you go an implant
is just ridiculous frankly the other
thing is that I just wanted to show you
something we did the whole is we found
in interviews we've done with chief
security information
an officer's is is there all the time
every day now have to justify to the
board of directors what they are doing
in what the security they are doing is
how much is it costing and how much risk
reduction are we getting out of it this
is is a theme that comes up every day
with Caesars and so what we've been
doing in the HP project is to try and
basically build a tool where we can put
the the operational costs of security
including the amount of user time that's
being spent on it intuitive where the
sea so can basically see is if I'm now
introducing this security mechanism it
will affect these users in the
organization it's going to cost this
much of these people's time you know you
can connect it to the salary but also
not forgetting the opportunity cost
that'sthat's basically associated with
consuming certain certain employees time
and so they can basically see you know
and balance the risk reduction and get a
better understanding we call the nsp w
paper usable security by stealth because
we're not actually really talking about
usability we're just talking about your
productivity and factoring into the
course that it's running and actually
think that's a better way of getting
through sucessos you know they're human
beings to their primary task is now to
to basically get risk reduction but
justified in terms of cost and so we
roll the usability in there that might
actually be a way forward of actually
really getting usable security on the
ground which so far I don't think we've
seen so that concludes our top 40 thank
you very much for for your attention
I seem to see the major hurdles that's
being run into here is the idea of
having your this be your password soup
that you have to remember the various
passwords and grace deal with various
means of authentication up is having
like a a program that that has a master
password that you enter one and then it
can have an encrypted file of various
other logins and passwords that that are
different and possibly i'm incredibly
cryptographically secure on is having
that one program with the master
password that can unlock your other
accounts by entering in the right
gibberish text is that considered to
hackable or to one's security and play
this methodology or is is that just not
widely implemented
but it'll work I mean basically this is
the Shania with the Shania solution
right I mean sort of like if you're if
you record somebody who looks after lots
of organization different organizations
credentials right and you can't afford
to have the same password on them you
need different parts words and basically
that's what he that's how he copes you
know he basically has this and it's a
personal its own personal master
password for in some organization you
have sort of a single fine or pop single
fine own of what you described there
it's the answer is it depends it works
in some organizations but the more you
know then you need people who really
from a technical side who look after
this technology based very well because
very often what you now find what we
found I mean certainly in one of the
banks that we're working with is you get
this automatic log through and then when
the connection breaks between the the
master password and the application you
know basically now needs to log it into
various applications and inevitably
several times a months for most people
it breaks somewhere and then of course
they have no idea whatsoever what the
password was you know and you need to go
back and recover the you know account
and basically set it's a vm you again so
it's it's a nice idea in a way but we've
seen in practice that it doesn't seem to
work very well in most organizations and
it's still you know you get a now a
lower number of incidents but but
they're still going to cost you a lot of
time and effort trade of things
we're trading off and I years or less
but use it with a business appointment
the master password goats and it's on is
usually a regular maybe
as one Beatrice you're going to stop or
one swell so I listen if you're happy
making that trade
clarify that approach existed long
before Schneider and it can be done yeah
but it needs to be you need to be really
I mean every different organizational
point of view the organization really
needs to be in control of existence and
what we've increasingly observed is that
doesn't seem to be having around
particularly the more you do outsourcing
in the more you get basically a
diversity of different different
solutions you know and other providers
coming in and it BK gets really hard to
maintain that and to make it 10 put a
mirror be linked in total godchild
Microsoft where and recent papers this
little icon touts believe it but inside
it'll certainly can all right it's a
system where if the master file is lost
but all is not lost so you need any and
you need that kind of backup because we
have I have a collection of some cases
of people who lost you know who
basically lost their master password mac
and you know flat fight or lost the
device where they've stored it on and
then basically effectively what you then
need to accept this that you're going to
spend two weeks of your life you know
basically getting the accounts back on
all the different different things Adam
don't much climax question a lot of this
seats truly to the fact that there's not
obtain feedback loop between a computer
security failure and a user choice right
that if I do something that gets my
system infected by a virus I might have
no idea what it is or if my corporate
email system is have I might not
so the option that I took that lens you
wish and so I'm wondering how much of
what you're hearing from the from their
people in the field he has to do these
things relates to the fact that they
actually don't know what really causes a
problem that's something happens
sometime in the past and I know exactly
what I did it's very very true and this
is in if we're if we're at all you know
basically I always think I'm very not
totally empty user education you know
but I'm just saying the idea that a lot
of security people have a bash it's just
fundamentally misguided and clearly the
yep we have the prom at the moment that
a lot of users can't connect the
specific behavior to a specific risk and
they don't understand what the
connection between the two is once they
do understand it it will influence the
perceived benefit so basically it can
reduce the perception because they
realize you know they're going to
benefit to their personal and also most
people are not those vehicle and so if
it affects the organization and their
colleagues and so on their back to
benefit they will also also take a cape
on what you know most most people vote
quite happen quite happily do that and
but it needs to I think 24 it can still
only work if you start if an
organization really starts to
rationalize if the security behavior it
requires from from from its employees I
still think at you know when I just went
leasing we look at like like to
so-called security education programs in
two major organizations one and they
have actually had higher communication
professionals to design yourself for
them and that implemented something I've
been say for a very long time sign
translate the required behavior down
into simple do's and don'ts
so that basically done now when I
basically looked at it and just copied
all the do's and don'ts and pasted them
into a list i ended up with over 400
it's like and when you're 14 for each
company and I'm not kidding you this is
but and and you look at and then when
you look at it but basically there is of
course contradictions between different
policies you know and you're leaving it
the energy and as long as you've got a
mess like that I don't think it can work
it could work if you basically do and
you go back and you rationalize your
policy University you pull back to the
things you really care about and you
come up with workable set of policies
you come up with something that's
coherent for each user with that you're
targeting then this could work a mile so
on the along the economic lines there
was the argument made that the forced
reboots are something that should be put
back in the hands of users no I'm no fan
of force for groups and I think they can
be implemented the heck of a lot better
than they are today but what you see
with a lot of users say forcing
themselves to shut down their internet
at every night at 10pm or forcing
themselves to leave Facebook for a month
or what have you is that they understand
that they're procrastinators right
procrastination is is an endemic problem
for for users and if it's you need to do
this in the next eight hours I don't
think it's realistic to expect them to
think oh gosh I'm going to lunch this
would be a great time to remove my
computer I think that's being overly
optimistic about where users are focused
and what their attention is on I never
thought that's probably true it was it
wasn't
is implicated in idea in spreading the
rapist to you if you wish that was me
that's fine reports made at a time that
would be ambiguous not you know was
raised on net shut down for example
which it takes it to choke choice as the
user which could be a few months nobody
can also be busy I think this is
something where where we can actually
use technology well to become a lot
smarter you know because you and if you
and it's it's partly that it's partly
just dialogues you know between people
who understand the business processes
and what understand i'm not i'm not
arguing yeah activity fine would be
better what better could be but never
for hours you need to an email is going
to be sent to your manager please write
the justification statement for why you
took another for every basically doing
that we're forcing it up at the wrong
point you know the cost associated with
that can be absolutely huge you know if
you're basically interrupt you know an
important production cuts at the wrong
time then the perceived positive is huge
if you look at what happened with the
Google with the Google Aurora breach I
mean that was ie6 should get upgraded
that should have happened six years ago
but it's not to do University what we
also where we can get smarter is the
kind of signaling we're using we're
basically how we communicate to users
you know so basically if you if you had
like you know a risk meter sort of like
with passion you know
o Allah for shop where you have a risk
me w say like you've now left it this
long you know and you're in the value
that most people would find you know
sort of like the least you know what
would basically get around finding the
least worst time to accept you know to
best get that job done do you see what I
mean I'm actually skeptical there
because i think the other the other
economic thing that you see is people
have this concept of a sunk cost similar
to a sunk cost heck it's been three
weeks since I was supposed to reboot and
I'm not compromised yet another day is
not going to hurt but you need to again
but you can also balance it with liking
it basically once even have some
understanding of what the actual cost of
breach would be you know and they can
relate they can empathize with that cost
then it tends to make them miss actually
been trying various prime invention had
kind of context and it does seem to work
if you can emphasize like if you now get
hacked you know what's the cost that's
resulting from that for yourself and for
other people that you care about but
that connection it's again it's part of
that connection if they understand the
connection between their behavior and
that
to risk mood and
and you can basically make that risk
real as opposed to something you know
about slits the ancestors there isn't
some some best solution or work by
realization very individual in here it's
pretty clear and we'd agree that force
patterning on start up and start the day
with whatever else atrociously bad i did
putting it entirely in the hands of the
users they don't if you feel like it's
also to a really bad idea some of them
between that you know you're very thin
these two states think well I don't want
interrupt important feel very important
art I do you want me to go to jail and
this one hasn't quite spacious important
so you know we'll find some compromise
division and understanding your bubbles
who work with technical my people over a
newer scarcely savier and away and they
probably will and nothing who i will
make sure i briefed on the past day and
instead ever you do they want to inform
you what
through a secure Elsa teammate a
commercial industries usually facts
before I sign so you know it's like just
having that dialogue with like managers
you know you can find the right windows
of opportunity when it costs the least
you know when it costs the least
problems to them and that can make a
huge it basically we did that all that
years those years ago even MBT you know
for the password resets to basically
when you and be here forcing regular
puzzle pieces to make sure they get done
at a time at a time when it doesn't you
know when it costs for these two
structure IE when there's no slightly in
the work on certain periods of the week
when there is you know when when when
they're not at the peak load you know
and that like they really basically
under a lot of pressure finding like the
more quiet periods you know off target
and so just scheduling things that way
can make quite quite a bit of
but that is as I unset assuming you
can't do that in there isn't a general
blueprint you cannot out everybody it
depends on the organization but I can't
outside can't really know this
engagement between you know this is
dialogue between the security and the
business people to basically fit it
better ring to the activities suppose a
be minimally you could measure it right
I mean if you're gonna force a reboot or
force a pathogen to certain time you can
give I know you don't like what I did
but on the scale of one to ten how angry
are you happy what's already with the
sum of the cervix they're basically it
is my question Anna it seems to me
though the you kids approach this same
force reboot problem the other side of
become rather than decreasing the
perceived cost of you rather than kept
increasing the perceived benefit on of
like saying what if you get hacked on
look at the benefit of
doing a quick reboot there you can
decrease the perceived cost obviously
late they get so that the system
recognizes the one that user hits the
sleep button it waits five minutes wakes
up computer who's asleep sees what
programs are open put those puts them in
temporarily and start up before it does
reboot does yeah and those better to
sleep yeah they can minimize I mean
there's all sorts of clever things we
could do i think i just went to do it I
agree let's do it we could but in order
to figure that out you need to do to get
a better understanding you know
operating windows doing bad and that's
all of that would think that this is a
client such a diagram of any design you
can choose the users procedure under for
either happy or spending elsewhere it
have get more serious and the LCL so
that like yeah we redesigned you I think
sexy tier delete you know basically is
like like the university most people
won't do the secure most users won't do
the secure delete you know when they're
busy and they need to get on with things
but they're quite happy to you know if
you're basically just say you know when
I when I look out or when you neck skin
put an island purified just basically
run the secure you know just basically
put it on stack and then one the
security leave you know she had a brush
did you considered using the diagram you
should you consider using concepts from
social opportunities
can you repeat the question are you
considered using the economic concept of
social objects and using externalities
to move markets or organizational
behavior to a place in which that
compliance actually
no we have about it
there's many other things that you were
describing so that
providing feedback we
and you can either type resulted exit
demand
the software we can use it
and so there's a lord from hyatt spots
or we subsidize your behavior so that
the man actually increases
and the combination of those behavioral
actually moved
which now and we can
or maybe one particular company
the overall reputation of market does
care so
5-ball Caesar
so this is a key factor of talking about
that's great i think yeah that's that's
a good I've got some really good idea
thank you
that manage it because it also connected
on some other things we've been looking
at which is which is actually to move
the security build risky so that I
connected to one of the other
discussions we have is basically
connected to remember a shin
it's basically making their biscuits to
make it part of the psychological
contract and the job is to make security
part of that I mean there are some
organizations and industry sectors where
Billy is where they're seriously
considering this now for instance we
have any company expected to put on a
show infrastructure
it's a and it's part of you know you
really sort of like like making part of
the professional east-horse and it's
part of the assessment evaluation and
remuneration so I think there was legs
as well it was actually trial having
managers minus salaries yes oh yeah
securing cause of their warriors only
after your honor if your team back to
whatever else and give your paper others
is a horrible but actually I was like
like using the motivational best using
the motivational in a rather than making
use negative in which version to
actually use positive accessibility
so I want to go back to the
authentication stuff you're talkin to
talk and
you kind of pointed out that a lot of
the scheme is fall at different points
on the trade-offs ability to get back in
town security
efficiency
yeah those are conclusion that means
that is sort of a different method for
each other on occasion situation and the
past interactions
I know different it's the first one I
think we need to diversify and have you
told you okay so we didn't have you gone
down a road getting specific about the
situations in which nation year
regression earlier and web-based service
though the affluence and log in at
different is ambassador different things
it so something one cobol awarding in
having every one day and then the
depression things to you once means his
hearing such difficulty compliment each
other find employment which class words
that what we learnt these are the
positive even began so which are fine
point at which the reset frequency
overtakes basic
it's really goes well what time is that
I think mr. mayor possibility recession
we're running is at the moment in the
first trial is with passwords pins and
the rickshaw system which bishops of
there but we want to out basic here you
know it's simply because that trial
alone needs 160 people you know before
weeks we're going to run you know just
want to see how or well that's good for
we add the other methods is to it so we
hope you to basically get some comments
those people are positive that you know
tuition why there isn't a
one-size-fits-all they have a frequent
injury even be part of it you see things
like working holidays and some of them
HR stuff that injury often has a very
very punitive one and a very long
mission so it's only embodied they did
to reset their password which then they
can't use a similar position keeps the
mouth
the entity limits no mikata members
to get it together than he said it's all
there is raised itself petrol and you
think well they just no one ever used
actual part of all they do is
use it it's based users of whatever
enter thing but they are theatre and
could that possibly suppress
and we managed to just have a property
working one is always the risk
equalisation the way smoking with other
people who may as well do something else
but it specially let's find the points
at which is transition from that in one
stadium over this so we went it's me I
mean a basic yeah I'm now kicking myself
to settings and I thinking like you know
this stuff that we're doing now we
should have done it 10 years ago we
should have actually collected the SEC
to 10 years ago but it you know ask her
back were something else fine right you
know the way we're doing we're doing
this out into basically getting them and
we're basically using a combination of
with dunlap studies where we literally
have a clock units that we've measured
the execution time for different
potential so we know objectively on
architects and we're doing the field
trials where we where we asked people to
log in at certain frequencies you know
we decided to give them a primary task
where they need to university there they
get mudding a paid by basically logging
in and doing things and and the security
mechanisms just as one of it and so so
we need to we need a base to do that the
other thing is just to it yep get we
want to do a classification of different
tasks and how disruptive it is to
basically being logged out but it's so
we're collecting we're starting to
collect lots of data and in some
organizations we've managed to make some
remember if you can then connected to
connect it belongs in the company you
can basically look at the log in
frequencies you can look at you know
which accounts fail how often on which
credentials so that by putting these
please sort of like you can actually
triangulate and start to get a pretty
good
now we're hoping to build a profile but
you can say like you know if it's use
this frequently you know with these
types of users then you know this
mechanism is not going to work well I
think in general I would still argue
this we need to you know you would help
us a lot by diversifying and having
having a sort of a selection of three or
four different authentication mechanisms
for different types of morgan situations
they have in their working
I don't want like raising it but they
have other security conference they have
a scheme were they how did I the truth a
random computer saying great n company
XYZ soon after Bobo's paddled and do
pretended pretrial discovery of that
machine and figure out how much damage
that files can do it hey and that making
people you make any more cynical about
before security but it's discoverable
anything else anyone what's called
security now it basically it makes you
know that it's a way of making threats
you know basically under screen users
it's we're making is unsound what the
actual risk associated with an i
connected to their very own
the cofactor kind of the forced reboots
and enforcing enemy in a particular time
I mean the thing that it's that the
attitude that leads to that is is you
know basically says that you know I
don't know what everyone is doing right
now but I have decided that what I want
is more partner that you like and I
don't know who you are what you're doing
area you could be the CFO just about to
release the financial our day that that
is not doesn't make me optimistic about
the wilderness to like there's been much
security about kind of trade-off but
many of the things seem of the flavor
where for example if you make things
password policies two strong people
write them down and security people get
that big fo that's not the outcome I
wanted right-hander or or like the
psyches deficit can understand how
computers not the outcome they respond
to that but I'm not sure I yet see the
good they do buy-in from security people
that in addition there's trade-off that
you can be yes this is more secure you
know a is more secure than B but it is
only a teeny teeny little bit more
secure and it's a great deal less usable
I'm not sure yet i see that you know
that the waiting
I think they see that when a is not
different from be in terms of actual
outcome the outcome for security terms
it no no no no that the old attitude
seems to be you know I can't even
measure security but if this is better
than that no security st. I really don't
care but i hope i hope that the tool
that tool that Professor son parking at
new customers developed where we were
work with it because basically we've
tried this the best we've kind of
prototype of the tool and we're
basically work have shown it to done
sessions with various CISOs you know
where we get them said by the New Year
season here's three different scenarios
who need to make a decision about
security as the one is basically like
you know cloud computing password
cracking so you need you have decided
you need to our current to pass codes
you know for everything and I basically
them that say like you know maybe is it
that time to consider maybe changing the
security mechanism all together
otherwise it's a hot desking scenario
and I can reward so third one is no way
and it's all about because they are now
so under pressure to justify the cost of
it it's you know as I said don't talk to
them about usability just shown the
cross as an impregnable activity and and
that that gets you no then then that's
that's way of getting that I think any
moment we found you know when you talk
to them i mean there's actually very
consistent so really intentionally
to annoy you know and they don't enjoy
being this kind of life like hate figure
yes Leslie they said I mean they
actually when you talk about one of
Delia Shannon at a concert she's done
interviews with incisors and they're
desperate to change you know the percept
that they currently have this image of
being a corporate bully you know sort of
like they're like the office bullying
and they really say that oh we want to
be secured cheerleaders you know we want
to be like positive and we're going to
get everybody of what and you know they
and even those guys basically when it
comes to making a decision they can't
get out of their skin you know it's one
of those specific things because there's
this dreaded best practice that makes
them stick with it you know basically
like as long as I don't as long as what
I do it's no worse than what everybody
else in the no less secure than what
everybody else does then then then
that's ok the other thing is that you
know you but you get that sometimes them
it's the pier you know the peer pressure
and the peer recognition is that even
when they're very willing to consider
your spirit ability what their peers
think about what they're doing is still
ultimately more important than it's
basically it's like some developers you
know we say like yeah I also don't want
it
but if my my fellow developers think
what I'm doing is this stupid or not you
know they're not the most clever thing I
could have possibly them and that's kind
of like and you need to really like like
you know that's not going to change
until the actual cost of doing that on
the day to day operations becomes the
slaughter them so we have just done
quite a lot of options like so much
those would be in terms of prospects
people find it easier to cope with
longer process than 12
very character variety so if you are
trying to increase the security of
positive versus some sorta cool factor
inputs are acting or whatever else and
you're better off my bet is on the
partners rather make
so begin your getting the same security
point that is through and less material
so why do it to be pointing I'm taking
it's also the case that increasing the
length by just a little bit of space yes
yes exactly and it's actually its crunch
to one of the other stars we're doing at
moments especially we're just fine and
trading the complexity of the password
for delay so actually because if you use
slow hashing it will make the login
button longer to execute but for well
actually it's quite I don't know we'll
see it might actually seems it is
looking for promising at the moment you
know that I needs to sort of like medium
too infrequently as possible its users
will actually prefer to wait a little
longer frame executing a moral is your
character space have you done disability
studies when somebody's holding a phone
with one hand do I hate uppercase yes
yes I go to only good one hand to type
yes that for using more unified
communications policy oh yes the crazy
forms but that is again if i can i get i
would say like you know you shouldn't
use you know what you're using on a
keyboard it's not what you would you
should
the fact that we are forced to the kid
you should have something right there
against our tight-knit it's like if you
mean simplest when you use those about
it it's like if you ever have a
supporting task and you try and make it
as little effort as possible so if
you're using a voice channel you know
why not exploit mortality of interaction
and use voice of education that would be
from a from a user effort father best
solution in that particular situation
funny yo you're happy to run around with
an easy takedown yeah I think you might
have misunderstood the question you're
at least what I from the stick your
Totten on the phone to someone and you
need to enter pathological cohort like
what and reenter the power being wack
our entry you need to hold shift as
you're typing in that pattern and you
can't do that with one hand is the only
get to communicate yeah yes remember
what you mean you don't have a box with
we should maybe we should go wrap it up
there but Angela
you're on for the next two days and will
probably be wandering off lunch
interesting choice we've gotta go to the
commons by think it's kind of raining
these are major lifting the infamous
building on your category would be nice
just like that's wrong Josh of the corn
was that wasn't his business talkin